Якщо ви щойно прокинулись власне якісь
сіромаха і не розумієте що відбувається
навколо звідки стільки в мене то
постараюсь коротко вам розповісти перше
передумови Отже ситуація насправді
почала ще за часів коли найманці пвк
Вагнера пробували взяти Бахмут і
рівноцінно з тим як збільшувались втрати
найманців збільшувались медійність
пригожина його почали транслювати не
тільки його власний телеграм-канал але
ряд російських воєнкорів які неофіційно
перейшли на його бік і почали
транслювати думку
нетотожню з офіційною позицією
Міністерства оборони тобто була офіційна
позиція Міністерства оборони А було
справедливий і правильний пригожин якого
транслювали там ну з десяток точно
різних різного рівня волинькорів після
бахмуту бійців Вагнера отримали серед
росіян мається на увазі як цивільних так
і військових досить позитивно репутацію
Тобто це бійці які безстрашно сміливо
йдуть бій і не важливо які в них втрати
насправді про це ніхто не заду але зараз
у цій даній ситуації це їм допомогло
безперешкодно проходити на пунктах
пропуску проходити ті якісь передові
застави які ставить російська влада для
того щоб перешкоджати просування в цих
колон вагнерівців сам прихоже також
отримав досить хорошу медійну
популярність за рахунок чого зараз має
можливість навіть виростові який вони
захопили на рівних спілкуватися за
міністра оборони і казати йому що
чувакнути бо не переходить над тим ми з
тобою не ви Тобто він одразу окреслює
позиції що я тут ні- перед таким
прогинатись не буду все буде так як от я
собі вирішив До речі подібну ситуацію
очікував трохи раніше за той період коли
рдк заходили у білгородську область тоді
ж вагнерівці казали що якщо офіційна
Влада не може захистити білгородщину
вони самі зайдуть і це зроблять і я
очікував своїх рожевих мріях що
вагнерівці зайдуть на ті позиції до них
доєднається рдк і вони разом підуть на
Москву що ми маємо зараз вагнеріці захо
включаючи усі як цивільні так і
військові ключові об'єкти і рухаються у
бік в Москви пройшли вже воронівську
область по дорозі збили декілька
гелікоптерів і нормально так себе
почувають що робить Влада Москви Вони
намагаються якось перешкодити тим чи
іншим діям у тому числі військовим
методом було нанесено декілька авіадарів
по колонам які рухалися також було
знищено нафтобаза у воронажі для того
щоб не дати найманцям заправляти свою
техніку Путін сказав що пригожина треба
знищити пригожин сказав що в нас в
найближчому часі зміниться Президент
Росії як ці події впливають на нас на
українців станом на зараз ця ситуація
яка складається є позитивною для нас
тому що у росіян вже є з обох сторін
втрати як в техніці так і в особовому
складі росіяни втратили три гелікоптера
два з яких досить рідкісні Мі 8 з
обладнанням реп далі Якщо тривожну
раптом вдасться захопити владу в
варіанті розвитку є два перший він
звинуватить в усьому Путіна скаже що це
попередня влада в усьому винна відведе
війська і так би мовити помирий
слов'янські народи Тобто там підпише усі
ті мирні договори і стане єдиним
справедливим ватажком на якісь певний
час поки йому теж не захочеться Полісся
на сусідню країну з окупаційними думками
і другий він очолить весь цей процес
каже що він так званий маршал
головнокомандувач новий який веде тепер
справедливо бійців обій і почнуться
знову м'ясні штурми мобілізації все
більше і спроби захопити Україну так чи
інакше війна ще не закінчилась ми своє
робимо слідкуємо за подіями Я особисто
радий що хочеш якісь події там
відбуваються І я радий що в росіян є
втрати
без нашої допомоги чим це погано